each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
and now we're going to have Vinod from
microsoft research here at Redmond in
case you don't know him yeah here you
see is he's going to speak about fully
homomorphic encryption from the integers
enjoy okay thanks or this talks about
fully homomorphic encryption from the
integers this paper appeared in your
crypt this year and this is joint work
at Martin Van Dyke from RC laps and and
my ex-colleagues Craig and chai from IBM
Watson so over the past two days we have
heard you heard a lot of things a lot of
very interesting talks and and stuff
about the problems of computing
unencrypted data from outsourcing
computation fully homomorphic encryption
and so on and so forth perhaps too much
and this talk is going to be about more
of the same so let's refresh our minds a
little bit the setting that we are
looking at is sort of a two-party
setting but there's a client Alice who
is computationally bounded she's
resource bonded she has an input X and
she wants to computer program beyond her
input X and get the result in the
program P is computationally intensive
ok so she wants to delegate her
computation to a powerful server she
wants to do it while preserving the
privacy of her in which is a paranoid
cryptographer so you know she doesn't
want to give the server her input so she
wants to protect the privacy the way to
do this is to encrypt canonical way to
achieve privacy is to encrypt your
remote so she interrupts and sends it to
the cloud and now we want a magic box
which are takes a ciphertext an
interruption of X and a program and
somehow computes the result of the
program on the input X inside the
encryption ok so it takes two inputs a
program and ciphertext outputs the
encryption of the result and assume that
you have an encryption with such a magic
box you know you can compute this send
it back to the to the client she
decrypts everyone's happy you know
that's good
a fully homomorphic encryption is
exactly an encryption scheme which comes
bundled with this magic box something
that takes a program a ciphertext and
computes a program inside the ciphertext
so we are all cryptographers let me be a
little more formal what is yes that's
okay I mean people if people have short
memories it's not too much stuff okay so
you know again this is a refresher I
fully homomorphic encryption is exactly
like a regular encryption have a key
generation algorithm encryption
decryption and the extra thing here is
this magic box which is evaluate if it
is exactly an evaluation algorithm which
takes a program ciphertext computes the
programming side ciphertext so we need
two properties which are critical one is
what we will call compactness which says
that no matter how big a program you
computer on the encrypted data the
resulting ciphertext doesn't grow I mean
it's not like the resulting ciphertext
is as big as a program in that case it
would be completely pointless for our
application so we need subjects to be
small a number two so this is a
correctness property on the other hand
we need security which is exactly
semantics standard guldasta McCauley
semantic security okay so this is a
fully homomorphic encryption a little
bit of history which you already heard
from Craig stock yesterday this was
defined by this notion was defined by
reversed aluminum dr. seuss in 78 so far
we knew before Craig's work we knew very
limited class afore morphic encryption
either you could do addition or
multiplication but not both and some you
know a little bit of an extension where
you can do a number of additions
unlimited number of additions but just
one multiplication in other words you
can evaluate quadratic formulas on an
entertainment that's what we knew from
before and it turns out that if you
don't want this compactness property if
you allow the ciphertext to grow with
the function that you're computing you
have a whole bunch of constructions in
fact a recent result also with Craig and
shy we show that you can
such an encryption scheme from Yale
garbled circuit generically so this is
so it can be based on a DD h or in Al
w/e or any of these you know standard
assumptions so really the hard part in
constructing home are quick interruption
is compatible to ensure that the
ciphertext stay small this problem was
open for for a while until Craig
constructed a fully homomorphic
encryption based on algebraic number
theory and ideal lattices and and all
kinds of heavy machinery the question we
will ask in this talk is is there an
elementary construction of a fully
homomorphic encryption particular I
don't want to use ideal a disease I
don't know idea lattices so obviously I
can't use them and I want to construct
an encryption scheme which uses just
addition and multiplication okay it has
to be you know relatively simple easy to
understand that's exactly what what we
will show in this talk will construct a
fully homomorphic public key encryption
scheme which is which uses on the
additional multiplication over the
integers and the security is based on
what we call the approximate and
greatest common devices problem or rocks
when GCD and this part subset some
problem i'll define both in the course
of the talk okay so let's jump right
into the construction as a construction
will proceed in a number of steps the
first step is to so it's really the
basic building block is a construction
of a secret key somewhat homomorphic
encryption scheme I'll say what Sam what
is in a little bit so it's it's a it's a
it's a it's different from what we
wanted at the end in two aspects one
it's a secret key encryption supposed to
a public interruption it turns out that
this can be very easily fixed there is a
generic transformation that takes a
secret key encryption of this form and
converts it into a public interruption
and the second deficiency is that it's
only somewhat home orphic broadly
speaking what this means is that you can
evaluate a lot of circuits a lot of
programs but not every program not every
polynomial time computable function it
turns out that that can be fixed using
techniques borrowing from Gentry like
bootstrapping it's costing and so forth
so what I'm going to focus on in this
talk is the basic building block namely
the construction of a secret key
somewhat homomorphic encryption scheme I
think that's the that's that's that's
what I'll describe this talk okay so
jump right into it how do we construct
the secret key some automorphic
encryption the secret key is going to be
a large odd number p okay so n is a
security parameter let us say n squared
bit odd number p the interruption of a
bit so i will describe a bit encryption
for simplicity but you can extend this
to sort of large domains as well to
interrupt a baby i pick a random a
multiple of P a very large multiple of P
so this is roughly n squired bits excuse
the multiple q is roughly into the five
bits supposed to the secret which is
only in Squirrel bit so it's a really
large multiple of P that's number one
number two pick a random small even
number two times are right so pick a
random small number are roughly n bits
so much smaller than the secret x 2 you
get a random small even number and some
of these things together so it's Q times
P plus 2 times our plus the bit that you
want to encrypt this is the ciphertext
this is the interruption procedure how
do you decrypt well the first thing I do
is I know the secret p so I can remove
the multiple of pay part from the
ciphertext so taken bart b take
ciphertext mod p what i get is the
remaining part 2 times r plus b mod way
all right now the key thing to observe
is that this number is so small that
taking it mod p doesn't do anything to
it remains the same so like taking 10
mar 17 right 10 170 instead so it
remains the same and now the bit that
I'm interested in is simply the least
order the least significant bit of two
times R plus B so i take this mod 2 or
simply read off the least significant
bit i get i get the bit that i'm
interested this is the decryption
procedure right so far i used a little
bit of modular arithmetic
a little bit of integer addition
multiplication that's all okay so this
is the interruption scheme the only
thing I have to show you now is how to
add and multiply encrypted bits given an
interruption of b1 and b2 how do i
compute the encryption of b1 plus b2 and
b1 times v2 ok so given this you can you
can write any program as a combination
of addition and multiplication so you
can kind of put these building blocks
together to compute any any any program
that you want okay so this is this photo
let's try this actually turns out to be
pretty simple so very simple and the
idea is that a ciphertext is a near
multiple of P and if i add or multiply
to near multiples of P I get another
near multiple of me it's not going to be
as near as you know as closest before it
still you know you can set the
parameters so that it still remains
particulars okay so concretely how does
this work let's say we have two
ciphertext ciphertext of b1 as I had
extra be too right they want to compute
a ciphertext that encrypts b1 plus b2
how do i do this i simply add these two
numbers as integers right c1 plus c2 and
that's simply a multiple of P plus a
number small enough number it's a little
bit bigger than before but it's least
significant bit is the exora v1x or
orbital okay in the key thing to notice
that if I said the original noise to be
small enough then this noise doesn't
grow it it still remains a pretty small
compared to the secret key
multiplication it's the same thing
except that the expression gets a little
bit more complicated if you write it
down it turns out to be a multiple of P
again a number which remains small
enough although it grows much faster
than if you add you're multiplying two
numbers it draws much faster than if you
had but still it's Lee significant bit
is the product of the two bits you're
interested in and you can make sure that
it stays within within bounds okay so
this is how you add and multiply bits
and once you have this you can compose
them together to compute any program
this is what you do so we're happy right
i mean everything's great except for two
problems
one the ciphertext grows with each
operation every time you add to
ciphertext the resulting ciphertext
becomes you know the bit length grows by
one when you multiply the bit length
gross by a factor of two right so this
is not any good because what this means
is that the resulting ciphertext
offering computer program is essentially
going to be as big as program so you
know why does the White is the client
it's not outsourcing anymore so you want
to keep the ciphertext bounded so that's
one thing we want to do the second
problem is that the noise which is
contained within the ciphertext which is
this number are the right that I talked
about also grows with each operation
okay this is also problematic let's see
why that's the case a ciphertext you can
write it as a point in the number line
right so this is all multiples of
therapy a ciphertext is a multiple of P
plus a little bit of noise two times R
plus B and I claim that if if this noise
is larger than half the multiple of P
then you know your dad I mean the
decryption doesn't succeed why is that
the case well you're going to first
compute the ciphertext mod p right that
gives you is the nearest multiple when I
same on the operation gives you the
nearest multiple of P and and in the
distance between this and the nearest
multiple of P is some number R prime
which is different from two times R plus
which is different from what I used for
interruption in particular the least
significant bit of art prime is going to
be something different in particular
it's going to be the negation of the bit
that I that I encrypted so you know the
decryption is not going to succeed
anymore so what the lesson we learn is
that if the noise becomes larger than
half the multiple of P decryption fails
so we have to keep it under onto this
path ok so these are two issues with
this encryption scheme the serious
issues right i mean the first issue it
prevents the usage of this encryption
scheme in totally we really have to
handle it the second issue is also from
Malik okay so how do good this is
exactly what I said how do we solve
these issues I'm gonna just sketch the
solution right so how do we solve the
issue of the ciphertext growing solution
is fairly
simple you publish in the public key or
publish you know in the sky at large
multiple of pain a large random multiple
of being okay without any noise it's
just a multiple of P and after you do
every operation an additional
multiplication of the ciphertext you
take the result mod this this number in
the sky okay so what does this give us
what is this bias and we ensure that the
ciphertext stays less than X 0 because
you're taking it modular zero right and
so it stays within a fixed bound the
encrypted bit remains the same because
taking something modulo x0 simply shifts
the ciphertext by an exact multiple of P
and the noise remains nice remains
exactly the same particularly does not
increase and it the least significant
bit this is exactly the same the
encrypted bit doesn't change okay so
this is how we solve the issue of the
ciphertext growing right and the second
issue is that the noise grows with each
operation okay so I have two answers to
this issue one is that you know that's
fine but you can you can actually
perform a fairly large number of
homework operations already before the
noise hits this bound and that might
already be useful for for many sort of
low complexity you know functions that
arise in practice that's one answer but
what we were shooting for is a fully
homomorphic encryption scheme you're not
you're not happy with evaluating small
programs we want to evaluate every
program okay and this it turns out can
be handled by this very beautiful
theorem of verve Gentry who shows how to
take a somewhat homomorphic encryption
scheme which can evaluate large enough
programs large enough I mean something
that is larger than the decryption and
the size of the decryption circuit of
the encryption scheme and turn it into a
fully homomorphic encryption okay so
this is the blueprint that that Craig
was talking about yesterday once you
apply this you get a fully homomorphic
encryption
okay so this is the entire construction
of the sketch of the entire construction
of of the fully homomorphic encryption
scheme what I want to tell you about
very briefly is is the security argument
why is this why is this game secure
seems so simple it can't be secure right
but you know it is secured under a
reasonable assumption and I'll try to
convince you of this now talk about the
security of the secret key somewhat
homomorphic encryption scheme that I
presented so the security of the public
key version of it is equivalent to to
the security of this game because the
transformation is generic and it
preserves it doesn't add any more
complexity assumptions and the security
of the final scheme we need to assume
that a certain subset some problem
remains hard and you know that's it's an
extra assumption need to make let's
focus on the security of the somewhat
home or fake interruptions game okay so
what's the what's the complexity
assumption that that we're going to use
it so it's something we call the
approximate greatest common divisors
assumption the approximate GCD
assumption this is the name that that
how grave drama coined and in 2002 2003
i think but the problem was known even
before even before that under different
names so what's the problem and it's
going to be very similar to this
learning parity with nice or you know
learning with errors problem that
christophe and des and Chris will talk
about next end and the problem is a
following you have a box which contains
a large random odd number p an odd
number p chosen from this domain 0 to p
and you have an adversary who has oracle
access to this this box okay so what the
adversary gets is the following he can
press this button the first time he
processes but and he gets an exact
multiple of thing a large random number
Q 0 multiplied with me that's what he
gets but you know he's not happy with
that I mean he has so here's this red
button I have to push in many many times
so you know I'm going to push it as many
times to say like polynomial number of
times and you every time I do it I get a
multiple of P a large multiple of P plus
this noise
exactly the distribution of the secret
key of the ciphertext in our scheme okay
so so he gets a polynomial number of
number of these multiples +1 exact
multiple and our assumption the
approximate GCD assumption is that given
all this thing and polynomial computing
power you cannot find the number that's
hidden within this box namely p ok this
is the assumption questions ah ok I was
wondering white sorry so it's in the
easing in the ciphertext the noise term
so even and here the nice nice term
select random is that so what you saying
no so so so the assumption is different
from the security so the security of
this game doesn't follow directly from
the assumption and you'll see it you'll
see it in a little bit there are a
number of differences between trains too
it's hard I'll talk about this a little
bit but the security parameters then
right so it's a it's the it's a
dimension for which lattice problems are
hard rocky speaking and the numbers are
of size roughly into the five so and I
don't know what what the reasonable
value of fairness maybe something like
thousand and the number sort of slice
into the way so it's not it's polynomial
time but uh you know
the cute 0p is of size n to the 5n to
the 5 + + n squared but you know into
the fight freely okay so okay so this is
the assumption okay so how does this
relate to the security of the scheme
well the security of the scheme says
that given an exact multiple the number
of need multiples of P with random noise
plus you know bit that you drive on
encrypt you can't guess this built his
the adversary can't guess this bit given
one exact multiple and many sort of
approximate multiples so so clearly
there is a sort of a syntactic
difference between the assumption and
what we need for security namely that in
the assumption the assumption is that
the adversary cannot solve a search
problem namely guessing the number p
whereas britain semantic security a
priori seems much easier he just has to
guess this one bit of the noise all
right so they seem to be different
problems a priori nian and what we will
show is that they are actually
equivalent in other words if you can
break the semantic security you can
actually come up with this this entire
number p you can break the approximate
GCD assumption okay so this is something
that we need to show and out and what
I'll show in the in the rest of the talk
is a sort of an idea of how you how the
security proof course a taste of how the
security proof course okay good so again
what do we need to show we have an
interruption breaker which breaks
semantic security by guessing this bit
and we want to show that that guy solves
the approximate de sleep Rock which is a
search problem so the proof proceeds in
a number of steps the first thing I will
show is by a sequence of steps I'll
transform the encryption breaker into an
adversary that does the following it
gets an exact multiple it gets a whole
bunch of near multiples of P and gets
this this distinguished number which is
also a near multiple but I everyone are
sort of write it separately and it
predict
the least significant bit of Q in this
distinguished multiple okay so you'll
see why I'm writing this in kind of two
different steps in there in a little bit
so I claim that an encryption breaker
can be transformed into this algorithm
and I want the following property from
this adversary I want the adversary to
predict the least significant bit of Q
for every ciphertext C for every number
C which is of this form okay so so in in
some sense that the proof involves a
worst-case to average case argument over
C so the algorithm that we start the
adversary that we started with the one
that breaks the encryption only works
for a random near multiple whereas we
want to transform it into something that
works on every near multiple it involves
an argument which says that computing
the least bit of Q is equal to compute
it's the same as computing the least
significant bit of our that's actually
easy to see because P is odd so the
leasing a bit of Q plus the LSB of r is
equal to L SPF say so computing one is
equivalent to computing the other right
and hybrid argument and so forth but you
know this is something that we can show
using standard tricks okay in other
words we can show that an encryption
breaker results in an adversary which
succeeds in in this game in predicting
LSB FK ok the next thing we can show is
that to break the approximate GCD
problem it's enough to predict cue from
Q times P plus R and that this is
actually very easy to see because if you
can predict q you can divide c by q what
you will get is p plus a very small
number so you can take that small number
off and what you get is be so predicting
Q is equivalent to predicting thing okay
so what I wanted to show was an arrow
between the encryption breaker and up I
want to show that the encryption breaker
implies the approximate DC solver I
simplified my problem by doing these
reductions and what I the only thing
that I need to show now is an arrow
between these two problems right so I
want to show that an adversary that
succeeds in this game
results in an adversary that succeeds in
this other game yes artists are small
compared to be right so if i can predict
q I'm going to take seed and / q so what
I'll get the speed which is an integer
plus R over Q which is very very small
okay so i can take this I can round it
to the nearest integer and that should
give me p okay so all i need to show is
that these two problem is to go from
this adversary that predicts lisa can
convince 21 the predicts q itself okay
so look at the left and right okay so
the the the game that the adversary
place in both cases is completely the
same exactly the same except that here
he predicts one bit and there he
predicts so the entire number okay so
how do we show that how do we show this
implication well the main idea is to use
this adversary which gives me one bit
again and again using different numbers
see and make it so this adversary is
going to give me one bit the leasing
bring bit of Q every time and I'm going
to use this bit to make this number Q
smaller and smaller make this number C
and therefore the number Q smaller and
smaller until I get the entire q art
okay so that's roughly speaking the idea
so how could you do it right so what is
you know what's the natural rate to make
this work here's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna take my number see I'm going to
feed it to the adversary okay and he's
going to give me the leasing to convert
of Q okay now see that now there are two
possibilities one is the dls p is 0 okay
which case I'm going to take this number
and divide it by two and round it okay
so what happens is that i compute q half
times P Q half is an integer because I
know that the least significant bit of Q
is 0 times B plus a noise which is also
smaller by a factor far the factor of
term okay so so what did i do I made the
Q smaller by one bit so that's progress
right if LSB is what will I do in the
other case if the leasing room it is one
I'm gonna take C subtract B from it and
then divide by two ok so again I the new
C is Q minus 1/2 which is an integer
times P plus our half okay again I made
the cue the effect of Q smaller by one
bit okay then I do this again and again
I learned the bits of Q one by one and
you know I'm done okay so everyone happy
okay so people haven't heard the talk
before please okay good so the problem
with this blueprint is that to do this
step I'm assuming that I know p but what
am I trying to find out by running this
whole I whether it's p itself right so
it's a you know circular and that's not
that's not any good so what do we do
we're going to replace this step by
something more sophisticated and and we
will do this by proving the following
law you want to keep the overall
structure of the reduction the same
because it's so nice right you wanna you
don't want to deviate from that but we
want to replace the second step by
something more sophisticated so what do
we do we will show the following lemma
okay the lemma says that given to near
multiples z1 and z2 just Q 1 times P
plus R 1 and Q 2 times P plus r2 plus
this least significant bit oracle i can
compute a number Z prime which is the
following quantity it's a multiple of P
plus a small noise where this multiple
is gcd of the multiples q1 and q2 gcd of
the numbers q1 and q2 okay so this is
the lemma that we're gonna shop why does
this help us well because of two things
one if I choose q1 and q2 at random the
GCD of these two numbers is going to be
one with very high probability ok so
what I get here is 1 times P which is P
plus our prime which is much smaller
compared to be okay so I get essentially
p but you know with a little bit of not
ok so now I'm very happy because I can
take the second step which don't work
because I needed to not be and replace
the P here by this number Z prime which
is essentially as good as big and it's p
plus a little bit of noise so it's as
good a speak and everything everything
goes through okay so this is this is
this is what we are going to do and the
only thing that remains to be shown is
how to prove the slammer this is there
so the crux of the crux of the proof so
so remember this is the key thing that
uh that maybe i glossed over but so I
transform the interruption breaker into
this algorithm like this algorithm
succeeds for an arbitrary see so it
doesn't care about the nice
distributions it it works for any so
this is the worst case tab which case
part of day of the reduction which I hid
under the under the box but this is
guaranteed to succeed for NEC okay and
then I don't need to care about the you
know the distribution of heroin or not
okay so the only thing that remains to
show is how do you prove this lemma okay
so in a very high levels 50,000 feet the
main idea is that you want to run the
GCD algorithm the binary GCD algorithm
on q1 and q2 but the point is that you
don't have q1 and q2 you only have Q 1
times P plus r1 you know some form of
encryption of q1 right the main
observation is that you can still run
the GCD algorithm under the hood even if
you're not given the inputs by
themselves and the algorithm works just
as just fine because the because its
nice tolerant in some sense the proof is
very similar to the RSA we sort of go 25
years back look at the hardcore bit RSA
hardcore bit proof of firm
each or gold a container and proof is
very very similar to very similar in
spirit okay so let me tell you a very
high level how to how to show this lemma
okay so you're given to near multiples
z1 and z2 and your goal is to reduce the
queue inside the Z to get sort of one
gcd of q1 and q2 because you're given
these two things the first thing you do
is you compute the LSB of q1 and q2 and
this you can do using the using the
Oracle that you have right so now there
are two cases either at least one of the
bi is 0 LSPs is 0 in which case we are
in the wind the good sort of half of our
security reduction you can divide the Z
by 2 and everything goes through the bad
case is that both the BIS are one in
which case you cannot divide by two you
have to subtract p and divide by two and
so forth it's in that case we use the
fact that if both the LSB sr1 you can
subtract the two numbers right so you're
essentially subtracting two numbers
whose last bit is one and you get a new
number who's last bit is 0 now you can
take that divided by 2 and n continue
okay so after these two steps the point
is that at least one of the numbers has
an even multiple and you can keep
producing on that even multiple and and
then everything goes through you what
you get at the end is the GCD of the two
numbers inside the interruption okay
good so that's the security proof for
the person that remains to be asked so
what we showed is that if you can break
the semantic security of the scheme then
you can solve the approximate jcd
problem so quite another question is how
hard is the approximate g3 problem right
so this I'm going to wave my hands very
vigorously although you can see it so
the point is that this problem was
studied by how I Graham and also earlier
by ligurious coppersmith and gooey and
stern under various different names so
it turns out that this problem is
equivalent to the simultaneous
definitely an approximation problem
and yeah so what do we know about
attacks on this problem the tax a lot is
based ligurious himself or an algorithm
that solves solves this problem for a
range of parameters then there's
coppersmiths algorithm for finding small
polynomial roads you can approach you
can adapt that to solve this problem
then there is algorithm and go in and
stern and drag gifts orthogonal lattice
method and so on and so forth the point
is that all of these methods run out of
steam when I set the parameters
appropriately in particular when the
multiple in the site in the bit length
of the multiples is larger than Squire
of the square of the bit lengths of the
secrets so in particular this is
satisfied in our case because the bit
length of Q is n to the five and the bit
length of secret sense quite right these
algorithms run out of steam it's all
going to stop working when the
parameters satisfy this constraint okay
so you know this is evidence that that
the problem is hard although you know we
need to work more to understand hardness
of this problem okay so this is all I
wanted to say future directions say you
know this is the obvious future
direction construct an efficient fully
homomorphic encryption scheme the one
thing that correct mentioned which I
want to stress again is that all the
homework encryption three home offering
encryption schemes all of them use the
same blueprint they construct a somewhat
home or fake interruption scheme and
then they sort of bootstrap use this
bootstrapping trick to make it fully
homomorphic the question is is it really
necessary and they did them the overhead
of the whole process comes from the
bootstrapping procedures of the question
is is it really necessary sorry we
should each other three okay well there
is a Craig's there's the integer stuff
that I used to do and the third one is
this this encryption scheme of smart and
work out run which is similar to Craig's
original encryption scheme except that I
would say that it lies between the toast
games so the the assumption is still
lattice based but the ciphertext are
integers so somewhat lies between the
two schemes
okay so okay so not quite efficient
question is can you make a deficient so
there are some recent improvements the
first reference is Martin breakout and i
forgot what sss GH is generally in
tulare they implement the scheme and
come up with some numbers in performance
numbers ok so the second and probably
more excitement more exciting for me
directions to evaluate the security of
the approximate GCD assumption so thing
is the this scheme had says nothing
about ideal lattices right i mean all we
are doing is manipulating numbers adding
and multiplying numbers it wait so where
is the original scheme explicitly used
ideals and inner polynomials and so
forth this doesn't scream out ideal
lattices at the very least the question
is can you use some version of the
scheme to construct a fully homomorphic
encryption based on you know regular
lattice problem so something that
doesn't you know depend on idea lattices
ideally we want to sort of get a fully
homomorphic encryption scheme based on
the shuttle select a problem on regular
lattices questions can you do this ok so
that's that questions yes if it's a key
bits it currently well there are not
only none of the three billion bits but
you're saying and that's more like an
80s it is not good because 80s there so
the different security barometer yes the
difference agree it is a solid you're
talking 10 to 16 bits each number
my arithmetic is really bad yes yes
something like that day 80 works for the
end in this case because the dimension
of the lettuce is that you can also
serve
but also
this concept package
ok so
improvements yes
sir Zeila get into my Callista coding
search this is
good point so so the search her decision
for lwe is is it's lista coding
essentially reduces uses some of those
ideas
it is it uses essentially called 11 so
well then I don't know function
is it the real blue channel connecting a
clown question what was the most
interesting question of the day right
yes
any other districts
this
he's a pleasure to present Chris who
came from Georgia Tech know comes from
Georgia Tech sorry joint work and be
deniable encryption so you can ask
questions I'll just make you feel really
guilty by the cover about that okay this
is by deniable encryption that's a work
with Adam O'Neill also at Georgia Tech
as of a couple days ago now he's at
Texas okay so in the clouds now that we
have that end of the out of the way so I
want to talk about a totally different
concept called deniable encryption which
kind of started with some ideas of been
a low and was formalized the bed by
kinetic neon Ostrovsky in 97 and imagine
for the moment that Alice and Bob are
now siblings and they're trying to
prepare a party for their big brother
surprise party so they want to keep it a
secret and so Alice and Bob were going
to use some encryption and the way they
do that is well Alice a bob will have
his public key that Alice knows and
Bob's going to receive this message from
her so she's going to encrypt it by
taking his public key and then some
random local coins of her own and then
she will encrypt the message surprise
party and she'll ship it over to Bob
this ciphertext but big brother is
watching them and you know he he decides
using the methods that that big brothers
often have to ask them you know what are
they talking about what what were you
saying behind my back and he can kind of
twist their arm basically and say I was
tell me the coins that you used to send
this this message or Bob you know give
me your secret key and if he does that
then the the surprise is spoiled so
Alice and Bob really don't want that to
happen so what they would prefer is if
there was some way for them to encrypt
the message in a deniable way we're
going to call deniable way and so maybe
Alice uses the
slightly maybe she uses a different
encryption algorithm are called deny
blank and Bob should still get the
message that she intends for him to
receive but in in preparation or in case
big brother comes along and tries to
coerce them then they're able to create
some fake coins and maybe a fake secret
key so Alice can do this locally and
come up with some different fake looking
you know fake coins and a fake key so
that when Big Brother comes along and
courses them you know it looks like
something innocuous that they can all
agree on so basically the point is that
the fake coins that Alice provides in
the fake key that Bob provides should
look completely consistent as if another
message have been encrypted there should
be nothing suspicious at all about these
coins and keys that's very important yes
we hook people yeah we'll talk about
that I mean 11 issue is you know how do
they know that of course it has to look
like a consistent story so the coins
here should correspond to the same
message as the key as the secret key is
going to decrypt so there's this
question of coordination so I'll get to
that in a moment so you know it's not
clear that you can do this kind of thing
it seems a bit paradoxical although not
outright and if you could do it then
there are a lot of nice applications
that you might imagine using for it
naval they all pretty much come down to
this anti corrosion property so a lot of
professionals will often have ethical or
or professional obligations that they
have to give for example journalists may
have to promise they're whistleblowers
that they won't be able to be coerced
into revealing who they are or what
exactly that they they're whistleblower
delivered to them lawyers you know have
ethical obligations to their clients
whistleblowers things like that or if
you find yourself dealing with a
different kind of Big Brother entirely
you might want to feature like this
another application that has
traditionally been in connection with
deniable encryption is voting where the
idea is simple
if you want to vote for somebody then
you encrypt their name as as the ballot
and you encrypt it deny ibly so that if
someone comes to you later and tries to
coerce you into finding out who you
voted for well you can reveal whatever
coins you like showing them that you
voted for whoever they you know happen
to want you to vote for you have to be a
little bit careful when when thinking
about this because in voting sometimes a
person wants to be coerced and so you
know because maybe they'll be paid a
hundred dollars for voting for Smith
instead of Johnson and so you have to be
careful about whether the person doing
the encrypting is is trying to be
prevented from outside coercion or is
willingly able to be coerced so this
takes them care and and it depends a bit
on what your what exactly you're trying
to achieve here and then there's a
different application entirely which
doesn't a priori have to do with with
coercion per se which is secure
protocols that tolerating adaptive
break-in so this what I mean by this is
a deniable scheme in particular has a
property that's called non committing
encryption and that's something that can
be used to design adaptively secure
multi-party computation protocols but in
fact deniability is is strictly stronger
notion than non committing encryption
and yet it's one way to achieve it so
you have to go back a little ways to
find some state-of-the-art the only
paper really that I know of in the
theoretical literature is the one I
mentioned before by kinetic at all and
the main the main construction in that
paper was what I'll call a sender
deniable public key encryption scheme so
this means that the coercer could go and
force Alice to reveal this the coins
that she used to perform the encryption
so that's the the main construction
involved there and then if you had some
interaction and basically flip the roles
of Alice and Bob so you have now have an
interactive encryption algorithm or
encryption protocol then you can get
receiver deniability where the receiver
can be coerced but not
sender and then they get the what i'll
call by deniability which is shorthand
for sender and receiver can be coerced
via some interaction with third parties
but the catch is that at least one of
those third parties must remain coerced
so whoever is in the system there's at
least one person who must remain on
course and whose coins remain secret
okay that an accurate description yeah
okay good and then this is also not not
just desirable in theory but actually
the practitioners seem to care about
this problem quite a bit so there this
this product called truecrypt which
advertises pretty highly on its you know
a list of features in the front page
that it provides something caused
plausible deniability there's an old
apparently defunct software project
called the rubber hose file system which
is supposed to give you some deniability
as well what these actually give you
some kind of limited deniability they
allow you to say that Oh in this part of
my hard drive there's i'm actually not
storing anything here it's just a
gibberish that I kind of Pat it out and
there's nothing on this part of my hard
drives though you don't you know nothing
to look at move along here and this is
this is a plausible story I think you
can I think you can make the case that
it could work you know if you're at a
border crossing or something like that
it's good for storage but I'm not sure
it's so convincing of an argument for
communication because if Bob and Alice
are sending messages to each other
something's going on I mean they're
they're speaking I think it's not really
plausible to say well I just happened to
have sent Bob a bunch of random bits and
there was really nothing behind it
what's that yeah that I mean that's kind
of how truecrypt does it the cipher
texts are random looking and they make
it they make a huge buffer on the hard
drive full of random bits and then those
random bits slowly turned into cipher
texts that have messages underneath them
but who knows where that stops and where
the noise begins so that's that's what
that's roughly how they work ok so
that's that's kind of the state of the
art here let me tell you now what with
this work what we're able to accomplish
in this work so we get again what I
called by deniable encryption which
means that the sender and receiver can
can simultaneously be coerced by Big
Brother and in the most general case
they can reveal any message underneath
the ciphertext which can be chosen as
late as the time of coercion or the
moment maybe just before coercion so
that's the the most general thing that
we can achieve I just want to point out
that it is a true public key scheme so
there's no interaction no third parties
it's just you know Bob Bob publishes his
public key and then Alice can send a
non-interactive message by encrypting to
that public key it's going to use some
special properties of lattice based
encryption schemes won't be until the
last slide that will actually see a
lattice but we'll kind of see abstractly
what it is about these encryption
schemes that make it possible one
downside is that the scheme in its full
generality has very large keys so the
secret key in particular is large and
the public keys are accordingly as large
unfortunately this pretty easy
information theoretic argument says that
this has to be so if you really want to
be able to reveal any message chosen at
the time of coercion so the point is
that if I've got a public key and then
there's a ciphertext and I want to be
able to reveal a secret key that could
be of any you know 2 to the K possible
messages then there have to be at least
2 to the K possible secret keys that can
reveal because decryption is going to
have to work and decrypt
that fixed ciphertext to any of 2 to the
K possible messages so I need two to the
K possible keys that means there are at
least the keys or of length K so large
keys downside its inherent but you can
get around it and the way of getting
around it is something called plan ahead
deniability which is the notion also
from the CDN Oh paper and here we're
able to use short keys and the the
difference here is that there's a
bounded number now of alternative
messages and these are decided at
encryption time so like I showed you on
the first slide it's surprise party
here's the plans and then you know dad
is was so lame today and those are the
two messages that now Alice and Bob will
be able to equivocate to when when the
when coercion time comes but the
advantage of this is that the secret key
now is independent short independent of
the message length and another plus
about this for sure stuff who's not here
you can tell them later is that there's
no issue with agreement now of which
message they need to consistently open
it as so the fake message is kind of
baked into that cipher text that was
sent over and you know assuming that one
of these is a bombshell whistleblow
document and another is something
innocuous it's pretty clear which one
they're going to want to open it up to
yeah you can encrypt arbitrary messages
yeah so the two messages you know the
bombshell whistle blowing and the more
innocuous plans for the party are both
you know can are arbitrary but then they
can open them to either either of the
two wait around ok so is it pretty clear
all of this is without a formal
definition yet but well
yes the receiver has to receive the
sacrifice in both cases yeah and that's
that's actually necessary as well if you
don't have the ciphertext and you then
commit to a secret key than the
correctness requirement requires that if
you give out the key first and then any
cipher texts will have to actually
decrypt to what it it's real me
but thinking it's going to inherently
have to rely which
all right good so let's see oh good and
then actually one automatic consequence
of this is that we get improved in
constructions of non coming encryption
in particular in the lattice scenario
because the best-known lattice based non
committing encryption is three round
it's a rather three flow so it's an
interactive one and now we have not
interactive so that's just a plus okay
so let me give you a definition of
sender deniability there's a few
different ways you could imagine
defining this and there so we'll just do
one for the moment and then talk about
some variations you might consider so as
with any public key encryption scheme we
have a normal keygen encrypt and decrypt
algorithms and then I'm also going to
ask for what's called what we'll call a
deniable encryption algorithm and a
faking algorithm and these are for the
sender so as just as a warm-up we're
going to do just a sender deniable
scheme ascender deniable definition so
the definition is pretty easy to to
write down let's just say for the moment
that the messages are bits so we're
asking that for any two bits b and b
prime on the one side we have the actual
experiment where a key gets generated
and the bit B gets encrypted and then
the view of the adversary is everything
well not everything but it's everything
from the sender side so you get to see
the public key the ciphertext and then
you get to see the coins are that the
sender used so this corresponds to the
coercer came to this the receiver to the
rather to the sender coarser course the
sender and got their real coins okay and
then on the right hand side we have
something like that we generate the key
pair but then the sender now will deny
ibly encrypt this bit B prime which
could be the same or could be different
as what's in the left and then at the
time of coercion the sender will now
create some fake coins our star using
its knowledge of the previous coins in
the previous bit and then give out well
now it hands the fake coins to the
coarser so what this the nice trick
about this is that this definition by
its
self is strong enough to give you
semantic security and and other nice
properties so this is kind of all you
need for this yeah so if you want to
fake in this case I mean in the for the
definition itself you would keep the
original coins around unit sorry so it's
actually nice in operation you don't
need I mean depending on the scheme you
sometimes don't even need to remember
the coins that you use for encryption
but you can then get them from the
cipher text itself the answer is it
depends so sometimes you might have to
store them at other times you might not
but right if you can race you say i
erased them right and right right so
that that's just the thing if you if you
weren't going to keep your coins in the
first place you might tell the coercer
that you didn't keep your coins around
and not give them anything so actually
we'll talk about that in a second what
does what that means ok so this is a
pretty pretty simple definition to wrap
your head around a couple of just a
variant you could consider is one thing
I just want to point out is that the
encryption here is one algorithm and
then the other possibly separate
different algorithm deniable encrypt
that you're running if you want to
create a fake able ciphertext so you can
also consider requiring just a single
encryption algorithm and there's
basically a generic transformation that
will just do a mix and match of these
two so you can create a joined single
algorithm from joining up the egg here
and the den Encke so it's just it's a
generic transformation one one caveat
there is you only get a 1 over poly
distinguishing advantage there so it's a
the genera it's a parody the parity
trick so too I mean to what i would do
is if it's a bit hard to say in words if
i wanted to encrypt a bit be then i will
do
a random I'll do let's say K times I'll
run either this or this each time a
random choice one of the two K times and
then I'll encrypt bits which may be X or
to the real bit that I want to send and
then all I need is to flip one of these
denix the tune Inc yeah so that that's
basically the generic check there ok so
that's just the warm-up sender
deniability so let's think the real
definition that we want to achieve is by
deniability we again have three the
three normal algorithms as before and
then we have the deniable key gen as
well as a deniable link encrypt and we
have then a faking algorithm for both
the sender and the receiver ok so the
again we ask that these two experiments
be indistinguishable this is exactly the
one before except now the the coercer
owns the whole world so this experiment
happens and then the coercer gets not
only the public key but the secret key
not only the ciphertext but also the
randomness of the sender and that's
everything in the world ok and then what
we ask on the right side is now the
sender and receiver are going to run the
deniable algorithms instead and the
deniable generator will output a PK but
then something we call an faking key so
this might be a different behaving thing
it's a faking key deniable encryption is
the same it takes the public key in the
bit and then these two are going to fake
something so the receiver will now use
his faking key and the ciphertext that
he's received to fake a give a fake
secret key which should look like look
like this secret key in a real honest
experiment and send the sender does
exactly the same thing as before and
note that the inputs to these two faking
algorithms are independent so there's
not I mean they can run them locally
sorry
yeah yeah so the be here has to be the
same thing but but that's it what's up
Ellie on the ciphertext I mean right so
the ciphertext is public information so
the B is the coordination here as I
mentioned before if you're doing plan
ahead then there's no coordination
needed i mean the b is implicit it's
already in the ciphertext so with plan
ahead deniability there's no be here in
either of those okay and then I mean
just the technical point is that the
receiver faking algorithm here I've got
it out putting a fake secret key you
could even ask it to output fake coins
for the key generator which is strictly
which is at least as powerful in fact
that's what our scheme does it up with
coins for the key gen but just thinking
about it as a secret key is the most
convenient thing to do and we can
consider merging key gen and deniable
gen together into one and that all works
as well just generically so for clarity
I think it's a bit easier to think about
two different algorithms you know actual
deniable algorithms and then using the
faking to produce the fake secret key
and coins yeah and this will get this
will have a negligible
indistinguishability and then if you
join them then you'll get that one over
poly thing which is a little bit of an
annoyance okay so I just want to spend a
couple slides yeah it comes well it's a
distance the distinguishing advantage
between the whole two experiments if you
were to use a unified key gen and a
unified encrypt and it comes even with
one side even if you only need to do it
for one side and and it's the same if
you do it for both sides yeah yeah
correct that's right yeah this is kind
of an artifact of this the parody thing
kind of only goes in one way of them you
know okay so maybe a slight
philosophical digression or discussion
is whether any of this is meaningful so
the first thing when when we talk about
deniability that that people often reply
is well everybody knows you're running a
deniable algorithm and everyone knows
the phone coins and keys could be fake
so you know who do you think you're
fooling don't be a jerk and do you're
absolutely right to be thinking of this
we're not fooling anybody so the point
is not to convince your coercer that you
actually sent something but instead to
actually preempt them from being able to
coerce you in the first place so let me
unpack that a little bit you know think
about the most perfectly secure secret
communication you could imagine like
talking through a lead pipe you know to
and only the person on the other end can
hear it then this is inherently deniable
whatever went through that pipe later on
you know it's gone it's ephemeral and
later on nobody can pin you down on what
what was said through that pipe but
encryption on the other hand is
typically like entirely coercive ille so
if you send a ciphertext across there's
only one possible meaning that that
cipher texts could have had okay so this
is this is trying to undo that
undesirable side effect of encryption as
as a tool for a confidentiality so the
purpose is again not too convinced the
course or an event of anything but to
use a scheme which then does not open
yourself up to being coerced in the
first place so it's the pre-emptive
aversion and to be able to give a
completely you know non falsifiable
credible explanation for what happened
that can't be disproved and explains you
know everything that you could have
possibly done a second obligation or a
second objection rather and something
people think about well can't the user
just say well I just erased my coins I
don't have them you know when the
coercer comes calling in fact it was
part of my protocol to erase them so
sorry I have nothing for you and and
isn't you know it morally equivalent to
just saying I don't have them even if
you do and I think I think not I think
there's a qualitative difference between
erasing or claiming that you don't have
something and being able to give away a
fake explanation for it one is that you
might be in a regime where you're
subject to audit or something like that
and so you're required to keep all your
actions you know if you're in the
financial industry or something like
that then you have to keep all your
randomness and then if you get a
subpoena you'd have to surrender it and
then another is that you know for sender
ascender creating a ciphertext it is
kind of plausible that well they created
they chose the random coins they needed
to produce the ciphertext and then and
then threw them away they were ephemeral
there's no reason to keep them around
which is the point we were mentioning
earlier but for a receiver it's really
essential that the receiver keeps his
secret key around the whole point is
that he has a secret key to be able to
decrypt so it's not really a credible
thing to say oh I just happened to over
race my secret key even though you know
I'm supposed to use it to decrypt so
anyway that's that's my justification
for why I think this is a meaningful
motion alright so let's do some
technical stuff this is a tool for
deniability called translucent sets that
was introduced in CDN oh and the idea is
that you've got the public public key
public some description of what's called
a translucent set and it comes with the
secret key secret trapdoor and the set
is basically you just have a universe
let's say it's like all k bit strings
and within this universe there's a set p
of special strings and so this is the
property of a translucent set if you're
given PK then you can sample from this
little pset here ok you can efficiently
sample from it and of course you can
sample from you just by picking at a bit
random string so you can sample from P
and the main property is that a P sample
is pseudo random so it looks like a you
sample can't distinguish given only the
public key you can't distinguish whether
something is from P or from all of you
and so this immediately means that it
can be faked as a you sample it so if
you pick from p you can actually claim
that it came from you I have this K bit
string it's K bits and I say well these
are just the K random bits that I chose
when I was sampling from you and nobody
can convince you other you know nobody
can be convinced otherwise so this
allows you to claim that even though you
you know even though you picked a P it
allows you to claim that you picked from
you nice idea now given the secret key
you can actually distinguish there's
this trapdoor allows you to distinguish
between a PNAU and so that's what's
going to allow the decryptor to get the
true message of the true meaning rather
than the the faked one so there are many
instantiations of this idea you can do
it from pretty much general assumptions
trapdoor permutations decision
diffie-hellman lattices pretty much any
assumption you like so let's see how
this would give us deniability you were
going to define the normal encryption
algorithm as follows if you want to
encrypt a zero bit you'll send to you
samples and if you want to encrypt a
1-bit you'll send to you and then a p if
you wanted to encrypt something dinaya
bleeh then a zero would become a p and a
P and a one would be the exact same as
before just a you p okay and Bob can use
his secret key to tell exactly which is
you and which is P and so he can decode
the right answer here so he's just going
to decode if he sees two of the same
thing he calls it he 0 if he sees a unit
P calls at one and that's all so let's
see how this allows deniability it
allows Alice when she gets coerced to
fake things because she can always claim
a P is actually she can always claim
even though it's a P she can claim that
it's a you wherever she wants so you can
just kind of check if she created a
deniable ciphertext either a 0 or 1 she
can always go to a zero or one up top
just by turning peas in to use and
claiming them so that's that's just an
easy check and the problem is what
happens when bob gets course because the
secret key allows actually reveals the
true
the true values okay so this is
precisely the the technical problem
we're going to address and it's
something we're calling by translucent
sets so the main properties there's
couple of main properties is that the
first is that a public key now has many
different secret keys and each of them
are going to give you a slightly
different behavior when you test which
whether a sample is a you sample or a
piece ample okay so the test is just
slightly different so if I have you know
if I have one secret key it might call
these things peace p values but if I
have a different secret key am I call
these Peavy leaves so my own test is
slightly fuzzy and it depends on exactly
which secret key ahold and now for a if
I if I'm given a P sample that was
chosen by the sender then most secret
keys that i could have are going to
classify it correctly so they'll call it
a P sample with very high with
overwhelming probability okay but there
are some very rare secret keys which
will miss classify this this value X
here and moreover if I have the faking
key for this for this translucent set
then I can actually generate a
good-looking secret key so a perfectly
valid looking secret key that's going to
cause this this miss classification okay
so it's crucial here that I'm util i'm
looking at x and i'm using my faking key
to actually find a particular sk star
that's going to give me exactly the
wrong decryption it's going to call it a
you even though it thinks it's a p even
though it really is a p and this is
essentially what's going to allow us to
fake for the receiver Bob to fake the
secret key and it's really crucial here
that this be a good-looking secret key I
mean you could come up with some totally
bogus secret key that just causes the
decryption algorithm to crash and that
you know that would be something but the
secret key looks abnormal it's not
something that would be encountered in
in real life so that's not going to
convince a coercer
okay so we're really going to have to to
work pretty hard to get a good looking
secret key here so everything clear at
least abstractly all right so now I
think we're going to have a picture of a
lattice yeah yeah I wish I could do it
both ways but I don't know how to do it
both ways so if I could take a you
sample and come up with a secret key
that makes it look like a pea sample
then we would have solved this one over
poly issue and I mean you can imagine
possibly there's a way to do it but so
far no luck so maybe maybe if we keep
working at it but in other words the
point the point here is that if you have
the faking key you can induce like what
we'll call an oblivious miss
classification of a pea sample so
oblivious meaning when you do the
decryption using that fake secret key it
gives you the wrong answer but you don't
know it gave me the wrong answer that's
crucial that you don't recognize that
when it's giving you the wrong answer
okay yeah right right right so if my if
Mikey my secret key is kind of chosen
independently of the ciphertext then
with overwhelming probability will give
you the right the right classification
okay so here we'll see how to do it with
lattices so we'll just kind of do a
proof by picture here good okay so on
the left side we have a lattice that's
the green points and the secret key in
the lattice is roughly speaking going to
be a random short vector within some
bounded radius ok in this lattice so the
public key is a description of the
lattice and then the secret key is a
short vector formally speaking it's
drawn from a Gaussian distribution over
that lattice and you can generate these
two things together and then the way one
sends a secret rather the way that one
sends a ciphertext is kind of the
standard way that goes back all the way
to i typed work of roughly how these
work
if you want to send a you sample you
just send a uniform X in what's called
the dual dual space and so what this
property what this means is that if you
take the secret key and do the dot
product with X you're going to get
something that's uniform so you take a
dot products you get a real value and it
will be uniformly distributed modulo 1
so that's fractional value fractional
part will be uniform the reason this
that's so is well X is uniform if you
take the dot product of any primal
vector with any dual vector you get an
integer so that's going to be one fact
that we're using so you get an integer
and then this other part is uniform over
the fractional part okay so that's how
you send a you sample a P sample is an X
that's very close to this duel lattice
so you take a point in the duel and you
add a little bit of Gaussian error and
you send that over as the ciphertext and
the nice property here is if you take a
dot product of the secret key with X
it's going to be very close to an
integer and the reason is simply that SK
dotted with this point is exactly an
integer and then sksk data at that point
has to be still very close to an integer
so you can distinguish a you sample from
a piece sample and yet an X chosen close
to the dual versus uniformly in the duel
is these two or things are
indistinguishable and you can show this
using learning with errors good so this
is the basic translucency this says that
you can define a P sample you can define
p samples and you samples which are
indistinguishable and but which can be
distinguished if you know a short vector
over here on the left okay now we have
to do the hard work of the receiver
decide the receiver deniability the
receiving receiver faking rather so the
faking key in this case is now not going
to be just one short vector as in the
normal case but it's going to be an
entire short basis of this primal
lattice and everything I'm about to say
you'll have to take my word for it we
have algorithm
for generating these things and doing
the steps that I'm about to describe so
what we what we have now is we want to
be able to fake this p sample X we'd
like to be able to come up with a fake
secret key that makes it look like a
uniform you sample so the way that works
is we're given this X and we're going to
choose now a secret key which should be
a short vector in this primal lattice
we're going to choose it highly
correlated with this red red vector this
little red offset here so we're going to
use the faking key to extract out that
red offset and then we're just going to
you know go some random distance in that
exact direction and then pick a secret
key somewhere from that neighborhood ok
so the dotted line is I'm going you know
north-northeast for some random number
of steps and then I pick the secret key
vector from around that neighborhood ok
so I'm just inducing this big
correlation between the secret key and
the ciphertext and when you do it in
this way the reason this is going to
work is that the secret key because
these two things are so correlated their
dot product is going to be very large
and because I walked out a random
distance it'll be random modulo 1 ok so
basically when you take the dot product
here you're going to get a uniform value
and so were you to decrypt it that way
it would look like a you sample ok now I
haven't I'm not really done I have to
show that the secret key looks good you
know it doesn't look suspicious in any
in any way so from 30,000 feet you know
the main issue is we've got this fake
secret key and we chose it in the way
that's super highly correlated with X
why should it look normal ok so the main
step here is going to be some
statistical trickery going on and
imagine now an alternative experiment
where instead of doing it by choosing X
first and then secret key correlated
with X we're going to flip around the
order in which we choose things so now
I'm going to choose my secret
in the completely normal way just as a
short vector centered at zero and now
i'm going to choose my ex to be very
close to the lattice but then I'm then
I'm going to walk out again in some some
random distance in the direction of my
secret key ok so whereas before I was
choosing my cypher text and then
choosing a fake secret key in the same
direction now I'm choosing a normal
secret key and a ciphertext that's kind
of pointing in the same direction as
well and what you can show is that in
these two experiments you get the exact
same joint distribution between the
ciphertext and the key they're basically
just two gaussians with some core the
same amount of correlation between them
and there's some some nice nice map that
allows you to show that they're exactly
the same yeah statistical yeah it's just
two gaussians that have a certain random
amount of correlation between them and
you can view it as you know I mean you
can view it as one depends on the other
or they're just jointly chosen from a
Gaussian that has some covariance so so
now what we've done here is we've got a
normal secret key and then we've
generated our ciphertext by this process
where I'm taking a Gauss a little bit of
Gaussian stuff and then walking in the
direction of the secret key some random
distance and under lwe now I can replace
that red stuff that little red offset
with actually a totally random x ok so
my random X now I'm still walking in
that direction but if my random X is
uniform my X star is also uniform so now
I'm left in this world where I've
actually got a normal secret key and a
you sample over on the right and that's
exactly what i wanted to arrive at
wanted so basically the point is that
the where you were you to fake a secret
key to cause this thing to look bad it's
indistinguishable from as if you had had
a normal secret key and someone sent you
a random ciphertext in the first
so yeah that's the 30,000 foot
explanation any questions so far okay so
just going to wrap it up so the basic
scheme that I showed you just a bit by
bit encryption and it needs to use a
fresh key for every bit and a fresh
secret key for every bit pretty pretty
bad big keys but again as that's
inherent if you want this full like
equivoque ability so there's what we do
for plan ahead deniability is this just
a hybrid encryption basically you
encrypt a short-short symmetric key and
then you can use that to encrypt an
arbitrarily long message it's pretty
easy to see how to get this but it only
allows you to open this ciphertext as
one of two or some plan ahead you know
predetermined number of fake messages so
an open question really is to get this
full deniability like a unified key gen
and encrypt algorithm and with the full
you know negligible distinguishing
advantage pretty close hope you know
maybe there's some way to do it fake a
you sample as a piece in a pool but we
don't quite see it yet and then the
other thing is is kind of weird we only
know how we worked pretty hard we only
know how to do this with lattices it
seems like a pretty nice abstract
definition this at least at the level of
translucency and it should be possible
to get it from other kinds of
assumptions we have maybe a candidate
based on pairings but it's it's unclear
whether it works yet but I don't know
you need this somehow to have this
oblivious decryption error like a very
rare a decryption error that you can't
recognize when it happens but you can
force it to happen if you have a so I
don't know I think it's a nice a nice
primitive it should be in stantial from
other assumptions and should have other
applications as well but you know the
search goes on thanks
yes plane I had been out doing the about
my practical side and I have a paper
that kids get the
it is projected all the time yeah not
bring list and the reason is you touch
on that that I'd like the motivation so
so the mean prison like that is the
pollak if you're going to use like a
specialized system like yours people I
mean you're really cheating right
because if you are somehow increasingly
using you want to send reliable messages
okay so environment you in touch before
like you have a regime that enforcing
two persons i've used this system but
use of the maca so you cannot directly
so how would you respond to that i mean
i had our time responding to this convex
i mean the thing that that i would argue
and will argue and the paper is that if
you're in a regime which is going to
force you to use a committing encryption
scheme and provably committing then
that's you know that's where your left
where you're living and you might as
well posit a regime where encryption is
not allowed at all
so the question really is not so much
that are you cheating by just using this
I mean someone can say well why are you
using crypto in the first place if you
have nothing to hide and I think this
argument is kind of kind of bogus and
has been shown to be so but the point is
not to really say that you can you know
that you're out to cheat or anything
like that it's really to prevent
coercion in the first place so and you
can't say you know in the future what's
going to happen you know if you were
some human rights worker in China or
something like that or you need to cross
borders between regimes it's entirely
within your you know prerogative to use
these kinds of things and I don't know I
say it's hard to live it so the ideal
solution will be something like using
some standard encryption scheme right
hey good night that's actually one thing
I wanted to point out the encryption
scheme that we define here is actually
quite natural it's not absurdly
you know pathological and how it
operates it's almost I mean you can view
it as kind of a twist on I tied the
workers and look it just happens to have
this deniability feature to it so you
can argue that you're you're using the
scheme for other properties that you may
like of it and happen sep deniability
depends if you're officially play I hate
well it's a different definition but I
think you can
then I will encryption on different
assumptions yeah so I think David yeah
just in particular electronic voting
would be a place where we do actually
have my ability is
lets you you actually have my head this
is a list via who the candidates
there was a fake e which is a sort of
mazes crazy with a big but other than
asks for this show is basic and he can
actually find gun you can then you can
see what the real message okay and you
say look I don't have it I never had it
in the first place what yeah I mean if
you are using this fighting and we are
using the system probably we can also
generate this sword base
I never generated so he gets access to
you I used I use the recommended a key
generation procedure which is the
software default gossip we forget the
sandwich good writer okay to be able to
move this database to be able to fake to
take a secret key annual basis if you do
not get the bases you can of baked so so
this is lovely if you want to fake then
you can generate with the bases I did I
never needed to pay I never intended to
fake anything so I didn't generate okay
Your Honor leave the system that Billy
won't to face or you give the basis song
yeah the system just seemed really
natural as if someone has that so some
corrupts your system right now yes
absolutely so that I wonder wall between
coercion and you were drugged yeah I
want to distinguish pink origins and
corruption because if someone breaks
into your system before you have a
chance to you know create to fake thing
that you want and gigadyne so this is
really for when there's a protocol
involved in being coerced it's a
subpoena or it so the subpoena is
usually subpoena your hard drive maybe I
mean in one case you can actually
prepare a hard drive
fifty-fifty
human other structures a one-time pad is
not just inherently by denial but there
was a real live case of equivocation
undercover back in the forties good
that's it yeah so the one-time pad is it
meets all this it's it's a secret key
scheme of course but so good enough hey
it was is when you're purchasing mission
do you and foldable said with the
brother legal
of course that comes to you exist you
know I want to see this sineplex welcome
to this mess
and the two possible one who generate
this is the real each additional burden
in this case you get for that second the
texture exact text segments okay so
using the real encryption objects on
this case you get off that's right yeah
only you generally did you see the
movies you can equip it but then you
know that I know that you know the
secret key the short basis yeah wait
wait wait you're confusing something
because the basis is on the key gen
sighs oh so this is the encrypt is on
the sender stuff there's no basis so
again I mean I want to be clear that I
don't I don't think I you know I'm not
fooling anybody I'm not convincing the
coercer that this is actually the
message that was sent or received it's
just I want to protect myself and by
pre-empting the ability to be you know
coerced and pin down particular message
and so it's really more about you know
if you view game theoretically the
coercer is going to know that you're not
going to go along with it and so maybe
they won't even try or if they do
and you can't I don't think you can give
us a peanut saying give me the short
basis for this stiff no such thing ever
existed it would be like you have
subpoena for the unicorn
back in the yard correct so just look at
you two p
proceed orthogonal edu
my team is a flipper you to a pu you
somehow have to get yeah yeah I mean you
want to get a vector which is pointing
very orthogonal to the come it's roughly
speaking it seems hard just to make roof
go through when X is uniform out there
it's got to look properly distributed
let me go orthogonal E and I don't know
some somehow it just didn't seem to have
it here oh yeah super cute if I were in
England Russia too
yeah if so the problem is somehow that
when you even though you walk out in
that direction you've still got a sample
secret key from around that region and
just the radius of that is already too
large it's going to interact traffic
with the random acts so you can't kind
of keep it under control not seem to be
the Tucker problems it's no argument
possible
possible claim that yes it would be
right it'll be yeah so in been busy in
another cell i'm sending a ciphertext
that's quite all right well the they
actually the the prescribed encryption
algorithm is also telling you to send a
message to I think perceptive exit
epsilon that's that long I say so you're
intentionally having out yeah so you can
only equivocate up to however much
padding kept assignment on
or just in the new queue
% in your key every time the thing mean
we had this discussion before but they
opened by analogy if you agree and some
points a fake encryption and fake poop
frog didn't have more functionality
that's some sensors and some sense of
course people are skeptical as well name
is a come to you in the soil use the
kind of real algorithm make it sweeter
polity just take me like the situation
that you know you come to a service in
the service like a 10 ask if you want to
get like five bucks or not and you know
you say yes you can't sit no you don't
get it done even when you come out
somebody will tell you give me 5,000 you
say I chose know yeah something that's
so kind of game theoretically people
salute functionality watching you know
why won't you pick up five bucks but you
know they can't prove for more important
you said you know right that's I mean
that's what this deniability is about
having a plausible you know nan
falsifiable story that accounts for
everything
the figure they just have to this to
give to the technical needs to do it you
know the story apartment know what
but technically of the bishop you kid
another thing is denial Cristiano not in
any profit off the Nexus simulation
easier for you
uses a technique part of a larger
protocol you might end up finding
somewhere this makes certain
like much more efficient and you get to
buy in my abilities other properties
time for free so have you thought about
life our particular functionalities that
things were easy the truth well I guess
one I mean one consequence of this is
that you get now a two-round non
committing encryption scheme whereas
before we only have three round so
that's that's a
the positive side which if you don't
even care about deniability faking or
anything he's got a better
just to just cut out of this product
dump Russian but CCA security use like
coffee table read yeah pretty much
actually it's a group something like
just truly from the definition it is a
really good question I'm not I didn't
think about it too much but it it's not
clear whether it rules out CCA entirely
Bethenny you just you know they
the public unit 1.2
you could give him one quick but I name
in any other you can use public uniform
on corruption but you can you think
using Christian typical a symmetric
security that you can do so many
messages but just don't need to lie
about the tourism so the CCA question is
I don't know that it's like ruled out
because I'm here so
so this is the last talk and they were
just going to talk about we have the
technology now we're next all right
thank you very much when I want to talk
to you today is a little bit different
from the other talks we've had so far I
want instead go over some of the things
that we can do not we've had such
progress in cloud cryptography so this
workshop and the other work in the last
five to ten years of seeing
breakthroughs in cryptography we now
have homework encryption we now have
efficient secure multi-party computation
at least for some functionalities and we
have tamper-resistant cryptography these
are all problems are motivated in it by
practice and are making serious that
theoretical strides and what we want to
do with this I suppose is we want to
make things that were previously
impossible possible so for example I
recently heard we had a customer who
wanted to run some inference algorithms
over data held by our search engine and
they didn't want to reveal what that
algorithm was and we of course don't
want to reveal all of our search logs to
everyone in the world so that sounds
impossible but with the techniques that
we have today we know that's becoming
more practical and in addition there's a
whole class of people who would like to
move to the cloud but there are things
standing in their way security concerns
most among them and one of the
challenges that we have here is that
these techniques we're talking about can
perhaps get rid of some of these
roadblocks and move people onto the
cloud who otherwise wouldn't have done
so so I just want to share a few sort of
things I've run into they've actually
stopped me from running things on the
cloud and I want to sort of match those
up with the kinds of things that we
talked about in workshops like this this
is the Amazon Elastic Compute cloud
terms of service from Blastoise sent as
of last December how many people just
get feeling how many people actually run
something easy to okay well we know you
do yes Tom of course is our resident ec2
internals expert but I want
run an internal tool on easy two for
testing purposes to see how well it ran
on the cloud and so this is fine but
then I had to actually go read the Terms
of Service does anyone want to guess
which of these terms is objectionable
any bets anyone yes actually both of
those 441 and 442 or the answer in
particular this one that you agree to
give Amazon a copy of your application
so they can make sure that it's verified
compliance with this agreement I didn't
include all the context but really this
agreement is saying you're not running
gambling you're not running malware
you're not trying to hack other people's
computers and so of course you see that
and say we'll wait a second one of my
applications proprietary like a
pre-release version of some product or
if it's not even a to be released but
what if it has proprietary information
what if I don't know what verifying
compliance means that's fairly vague who
is going to see this application and
it's vague from this whether or not data
on which my application works on if
that's included or not so this actually
was a blocker this stopped me from
running something on amazon and so in
the context of the stuff we're talking
about today well you know we have some
tools now that we could address this
concern we could obfuscate yes exactly
and that's the kind of so the question
was could we give the application a
uracil Turing machine and the answer is
yes of course we could do that and
that's a sort of a crude form of
obfuscation right because it wouldn't
give them anything useful but how do we
actually convince ourselves that's where
we that's the sufficient thing to do and
so these are all different things we
could think of we could do some
computing unencrypted data to alleviate
the issue of having to give the data set
we use or one thing I've heard happens
in practice is people only ship small
amounts of data at a time to the
application in the cloud so they lose
some of it it's not a big deal but then
reasoning reasoning rigorously about all
these is one thing and another thing
that comes up is how do you convince
yourself
and convince your up your peers that
this is the right thing to do so another
thing it comes up when you start talking
about can I run very high security jobs
in the cloud there are these physical
security requirements that come up so
you have here on the left this is part
of a best practices checklist for this
standard called SAS 70 SAS 70 is not
super interesting it's just a list of
things you have to do in order to get a
certain stamp which then tells you yeah
my data center is good to handle super
secure material and these are all kind
of very interesting sort of physical
security things like you must have
bullet-resistant glass you must cut your
vegetation so the intruders cannot hide
behind it you must have a man trap Oh a
man trap is a sort of entrance device
where's two doors and only one of the
mill open at once so you enter the first
door it shuts behind you and then if
you're a bad person you can't get out so
you know we left but this is actually
fairly serious because the people who
wrote this standard we're thinking in
terms of that picture over there whether
these giant cages and there's one cage
around each property that holds a
different classified or high sensitivity
data this is not very elastic right
you're not going to have people in as
your ec2 going around and moving cages
on the time scales it takes a spin up
VMs and so this leaves us another issue
which is on several standards including
summon ones we have here require proof
of deletion if i give you sensitive data
for processing i need you to tell me you
deleted it or i need to have some Claire
I need to have some way of knowing that
was deleted now of course if you have
your own machine that's fairly
straightforward although not quite as a
drastic as this but then this imposes a
cost in a cloud provider which some of
them aren't willing to take and what do
we do about this from the point of view
of people who are familiar with
cryptography and know how to use it well
one thing that's sort of working
our favor is that not every piece of
data needs these kinds of protections
there's actually a movement towards
labeling data at least inside Microsoft
and some of the people are using our
stuff there are different ways to spell
it but kind of low medium and high so
around here we actually asked to sort of
say oh is this data low impact medium
impact or high impact what does that
mean well low impact are things like no
public web pages public keys stuff where
it's pretty much okay to be distributed
to any money an entire company we don't
really care if it gets out that much we
care but we don't care that much medium
are things like addresses phone numbers
or personally identifiable information
and then on high you have things like
credit cards passwords pre-release
software and that's where we started
getting these physical security
requirements where people start saying
hey wait a second you know I'm not going
to give you this data unless you can
tell me that's got guards around at 24 7
and we actually have this thing now
where the new SharePoint that's our wiki
solution will actually ask you to do
mandatory labeling of data so you can
know any given point in time is this
like the high-security the medium
security or not and what does dovetails
the work we're talking about here is it
says this is where you want to apply
some of the techniques we've been
talking about and some of those things
may have to stay on premises and other
things may go into the cloud so the
other thing that comes up that's
interesting is we actually scan for high
security data so we actually use an RSA
product that searches for high secured
at 'it's but that's been identified as
high impact and we look for cases where
people accidentally posted this data in
places that they shouldn't this is
actually interesting when you talk about
encrypted data because now you have a
tension between this product which we
liked because it sort of finds the
social security numbers people left
lying around on that wiki page and the
fact that the day is encrypted which
means it's harder to scan so this is a
question of you know searchable
encryption might be a way out here but
we do have these processes intrusion
detection is another one actually where
people say
wait a second I have encrypted packets
going through what do I do if my want my
intrusion detection system to actually
look at these packets and tell me if
they're good or not so figuring out a
way to do that without completely giving
away your keys to everyone who says they
need them for a middleware box is a
difficult problem so the other thing I
just want to bring up to are there these
audit requirements that are starting to
emerge for cloud services this is one
effort this a six group they have an
automated way of querying your cloud
provider to say does it have certain
audit standards so if you're a cloud
provider you can put up a little text
file saying yeah I have this
certification and yes I do have cages
around my data center and yes I do have
this kind of encryption used and the
goal of these guys is to have you as a
customer of cloud providers be able to
serve right little scripts that say okay
I can want to pick whichever cloud
provider meets these minimum
requirements and I want to just go ahead
and host my day of whoever's cheapest
today well this is interesting from the
point view of cloud cryptography because
now the question is can we actually use
cryptography to assist this auditing can
we use this cryptography cryptographic
mechanisms that we've talked about in
this workshop to sort of prove that we
really are meeting the guarantees we say
we are at lower cost than having hordes
of people from pricewaterhousecoopers
come in and inspect this every week so
for example this is just one example is
some project we have here there are many
other examples you can think of but we
have something we built on top of as
your blob storage which is just a simple
key value store very similar to amazon
s3 and what we do in this system is
every time you end up storing data or
getting data we ask you to write a
little what we call an attestation think
of as a simple log message that chains
back with all your previous log messages
and we built this in a way using public
key signatures that anyone in the world
can verify these logs so what this means
the third party can audit the use of
this system and say okay if there was a
problem if these
people storage or the blob storage into
corrupting bits or end up trying to
replay stale data a third party can tell
and then you can sort of say okay we
screwed up and here's some money back
for your trouble and that's just you
know one example where you could use
some cryptograms cryptography to produce
an audit trail that could dovetail with
some of the work people are already
doing in the community on getting cloud
auditing solutions and we also did some
you know performance and show that you
can get as a modest cost so if you're
interested in this we have an
implementation talk to me and I can show
you the paper and everything but what
this is all going is I've talked about
some places where we have some possible
synergies between what people are doing
in terms of policy and what we've talked
about in this workshop but the truth is
there's a huge catch up left to be had
between the people are making these
policies and those of you here in this
room so for example I'll just give two
examples one is over corporate policy
and the other is from European data
protection which I was lucky enough to
talk to caspar bowden who was here
yesterday and we got a chance to talk
with him both of these have a notion
sort of sensitive data where it's
difficult to move the data outside of
some perimeter in the corporate case we
have this high impact data we're not
really allowed to move it outside of
premises we're not allowed to give it to
even as your or even easy to and in the
European case we have personally
identifiable information there's a whole
set of things which are not supposed to
leave the European Union there are
complicated exceptions of this but in
general not supposed to leave now the
question is what if I encrypt this data
and the key is not available to the
cloud right so I cake and encrypted to a
blob and I put it on the cloud is that
still high impact data is that still
data its governed by these rules and the
answer is yes actually you do not get a
free pass just by encrypting according
to the rules as they are now now we know
that if the keys are handled properly we
know that doesn't make any sense and we
know based on this stuff we talked about
here that you can still do a lot of high
functionality by leveraging the new
breakthroughs and cryptography that
we've had and you maybe even get better
guarantees by having things in the
clouds and the storing them on premises
but the fact is there are teams who said
the requirements today don't understand
what we're talking about yet so inside a
company it'll be a bunch of teams and
legal engineering IT who get together
and hash this out over months and months
and months I had a chance to talk to
Casper and ask him so who an EU is
making these rules there's about 2,500
people who are civil servants in the EU
who make these rules and about 10 of
them know what they're doing from a
technical point of view so this is sort
of the thing I I just wanted to set him
up here and say is that look we have
this amazing technology but there's a
bit of work left to do before we can
make the policy rules catch up with it
because it sum up we have incredible
progress everything we've heard about
here today even if it's not completely
practical yet you know we've seen in the
last five years a lot of emphasis on
making really practical technologies
that can be deployed yesterday it's you
know Dana sugar beets tomorrow will be
the world but the question that we have
now is how do we make them you know
match up with the kind of rules people
are putting in place which are
preventing these applications from
happening on the cloud or happening at
all and then our opportunity is to say
how can we sort of dovetail these new
techniques with the kinds of audit
requirements and kinds of data security
requirements that we you see people
wanting to have and finally I just want
to say that there's an opportunity for
us or an obligation for us to educate
policymakers that another world is
possible that we can do some of these
things that we're talking about but we
have to actually engage and figure out
you know who exactly is the right person
to talk with and what will it take to
change their minds so thank you
you